did you know that two out of every three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
yeah i did for me i was pretty ball by
the time i was 25 i wish keeps have been
around when i was younger because
advancements in science i meant that
there are now treatments that can combat
the symptoms of hair loss and help you
keep the hair that you have it's too
late for me my hair's not coming back
but you don't have to be like me you
could stop your hair loss early thanks
to keeps keeps off as generic versions
of the only two fda approved drugs for
treating hair loss so you might have
tried them before but never at a price
this slow that's right if you were
thinking this is some sort of medicine
so it's going to be expensive you can be
more wrong keep starts at just 10 a
month how does it work well for one
thing there's no need to visit a
doctor's office just schedule a quick
online consult and a little bit later
discreet package will arrive at your
door and you can use it in the privacy
of your own home so if you're noticing
that you're losing your hair that's one
problem that's not going to fix itself
do something about it for a limited time
just go to keeps.com forward slash
biographics or just click the link in
the description below to receive 50 of
your first order and now today's video
today's ant hero protagonist was a
physics graduate at oxford and in later
life became a stand-up comedian
best-selling author and recording artist
but it's what he did in between those
things that made him a folk hero or
rather
an anti-hero at the peak of his
activities in the 1970s and 1980s he was
at the head of a drug smuggling empire
responsible for importing the largest
ever shipment of cannabis to the uk but
the reign of this anomalous drug lord
did not rely on firepower nor
intimidation it rested solely on his
charisma his ability to forge useful
contacts is inventiveness and industrial
quantities of cheek this is the story of
howard marx better known as mr nice
[Music]
dennis howard marx was born on the 13th
of august 1945 in kenvik hills south
wales his mother was a school teacher
and his father was a skipper of merchant
ships young howard would travel
frequently on his father's ships his
earliest memory is of him throwing the
sailor's cat into the sea the only
occasion on which his father used
corporal punishment besides this
incident howard was a happy bright and
studious child entering grammar school
at the age of 11 that same year he
developed his first scam by flicking a
thermometer he could increase his
temperature reading he could then
simulate a rare condition undulate fever
he spent weeks in a hospital ward being
fed medicines and pampered by attractive
nurses this is how he first experienced
sexual arousal and developed an early
taste for drugs the ruse could not go on
forever though and howard had to return
to school soon he developed the worst
possible reputation
that of being a bit of a nerd as a
reaction he modeled his persona after
elvis presley howard was a good piano
player and could hammer out some of the
king's most popular tunes to bolster his
popularity howard became friends with an
older bigger and meaner boy albert
hancock albert took him under his wing
and introduced him to the only nightlife
that ken fig hill had to offer the local
pubs around the age of 15 howard became
a fixture of the scene spending his
evenings swinging beer puffing on
cigarettes and singing elvis presley
hits for the other patrons when his dad
found out he was grounded for six months
but little else to do howard went back
to studying and nailed his school exams
at the age of 16. he could now access
the advanced level certificates the
subjects he chose were physics chemistry
and maths by day that is in the evening
he was still pursuing an advanced
diploma in booze live music and sex but
surprisingly he kept getting good grades
at school so much so that the headmaster
of the school convinced him to apply to
balliol college in oxford to study
physics howard showed up to the
admittance interview completely drunk on
beer but somehow he still nailed it
when howard first moved to oxford in
september 1964 he made an interesting
discovery attending lectures was not
compulsory so with plenty of spare time
he dedicated himself to his favorite
activities networking and chasing girls
the time for exams came along and howard
realized he'd studied little to nothing
not a problem though with a daring of
burglary he broke into the offices of
the examiners and stole a copy of the
test papers during his second year his
network of popularity expanded howard
was constantly surrounded by friends and
adoring girls former oxford mate john
nicholson said that there was instant
sunshine wherever howard went one of his
then-girlfriends lynn barber claimed
that he seduced her with two simple
words
come here during this period howard made
a new friend in dennis ervin a landmark
acquaintance which introduced the young
welshman to indian food
and cannabis it was a revelation howard
was hooked both on tikka masala and on
grass his room at ballior became the
backdrop of a constant party people came
in and out at all times of day and night
dancing through the wafting mist of
reefer then willing to explore new
boundaries howard accepted an offer to
try lsd the results were far from
exhilarating he plunged into a period of
suicidal miserable thoughts a bad trip
it culminated with an incident which he
shot at a passer-by with an air gun the
gun was not loaded but the intended
target filed a complaint with jon jones
the dean of the college the dean was
rather forgiving issuing only a
reprimand to howard who would not touch
lsd again freed of bad chemical
influence howard returned to his dire to
beer and weed during his final year at
oxford howard and two friends moved out
of college into a house in paradise
square they shared lodgings with a
heroin addict known to the local police
it was only a matter of time before
paradise square was raided in a drug
bust the police found the butt of a
joint and took howard and his friends
into custody once again the sympathetic
dean stepped in he talked the police
into releasing the boys and even
convinced howard to take his studies
more seriously and he did the party
animal was able to morph back into a
nerd when needed and he passed his final
exams but if he wanted a degree he had
to carry out several lab experiments
something he had little practice with
what he had practiced though was
cheating he obtained a set of experiment
results from other students and copied
them into his lab report it worked and
howard marx emerged from oxford with a
second class honours degree in physics
[Music]
the last intense period of studies and
cheating had somehow pushed marijuana
out of howard's existence he was going
straight no drugs little booze and a
steady girlfriend named ilse who he
married in december 1967. the two moved
to notting hill in london and signed up
to a teacher training course howard
however soon lost interest in the course
he had started drifting back into his
old ways hanging out with old oxford
friend graham plinston this was the
pivotal moment which set marks on the
road to becoming mr nice princeton was
not only a consumer of hashish but also
a dealer howard became his associate
helping shift his merchandise to a vast
network of friends first while based in
london then oxford and then later in
brighton shortly after this latest move
howard hit the big time when graham
princeton was busted in germany marx
contacted graham's old suppliers
essentially inheriting his network while
he was in jail in this period howard
left behind the last remnants of
respectable life he broke his marriage
with ilsa and returned to london to
expand his activities soon he was
controlling much of the cannabis and
hashish imports to london distributing
them to local dealers in southern
england when princeton was released and
returned to britain he and howard
continued working together this time as
partners on an equal footing their main
supply route originated in pakistan a
third partner muhammad durrani had
enrolled several diplomats who smuggled
the drugs via switzerland marx invested
his ill-gotten gains in throwing lavish
parties and showering acquaintances with
gifts and favors in exchange some of
them helped with selling dough at a
street level others participated in
setting up legitimate businesses as
fronts such as the fashion boutique anna
belinda's in oxford in 1971 howard and
graham were tired of working with
durrani and the pakistani diplomats who
kept 80 of the profits as they looked
for other smuggling partners they
considered jim mccann volatile man from
belfast who claimed to be a member of
the provisional ras the irish republican
army in a meeting in cork in the
republic of ireland mccann asked marx to
organize the transport of cars filled
with weapons from wales into ireland
mccann would take the guns replace them
with dope and ship the cars back to
britain
marx immediately refused to smuggle any
guns mccann was adamant that howard had
to ship something anything to ireland
they settled for pornographic films
business kept on growing so much so that
marx and princeton attracted the
attention of the british secret services
one of their agents hamilton macmillan
had been friends with howard at oxford
the two got in contact as macmillan
wished to exploit howard's network to
infiltrate the underworld marx
established business relationships with
crime syndicates inside and outside the
uk including the us-based brotherhood of
eternal love a.k.a the hippie mafia he
had been supplying them via an ingenious
scheme if a british band was about to
tour the united states marx ensured that
their amplifiers and speakers were
filled with hashish if no tour was
scheduled well no problem the welsh
smuggler would organize fake doors for
non-existent bans one of such
consignments was intercepted at jfk
airport in new york this attracted the
attention of the drug enforcement agency
the dea and the agent that would become
howard's nemesis craig lovato but before
lovato could do anything his dutch
counterparts beat him to the punch marx
had been arrested in amsterdam while on
a business trip interrogated by the
dutch authorities he spun a story so
unbelievable
that it actually worked no mr dutch
policeman i'm not a vulgar dope dealer
i'm an agent on a majesty's service i've
been hired by mi6 to infiltrate the
ira's drug smuggling ring or something
to that effect as a result the dutch
promptly extradited him to britain while
on bail awaiting trial marx was not idle
organizing shipments of hashish from the
middle east into the u.s in new york the
dope was bought by a powerful mafia
family the gambinos this connection led
to a very unpleasant experience the
gambinos had dispatched to mafioso to
collect cash from a deposit box in
amsterdam marx was to give him details
on where to find the money when the box
turned out to be empty the mafia man
paid a visit to marx he gave him a
beating and then threatened to kill his
family unless he paid him 10 000 pounds
in cash a terrified marx phoned his dad
dennis asking him to bring a suitcase
full of money which he had hidden in his
parents home when marx met the thug
again the man was apologetic his boss
back in the u.s had told him that marx
was an okay guy who didn't deserve that
kind of treatment to apologize the
gambinos offered to help him jump bail
it was tempting but if howard simply
disappeared then his parents would lose
the 40 000 pounds that they deposited as
bail money being the nice guy that he
was marx just couldn't allow that he had
a better idea in september 1973 a
customs officer showed up at howard's
oxford flat and took him away it later
turned out that customs had never sent
anybody to collect marks the police
suspected a kidnapping who could have
abducted the drug dealer the mafia the
r.a or
well maybe himself the customs man was
in fact a london friend of howards and
the two had staged a fake abduction
technically he had not jumped bail
by the late 1970s marx had become one of
the most wanted men in britain he
adopted a variety of disguises assumed
names and fake passports he later
claimed to have 43 bogus identities
including the now iconic missed nice
when he bought a passport from a
convicted murderer donald nice so what
was the secret of his success well
according to criminologist carlo maseli
of montreal university it was the nature
of his organization unlike south
american cartels or the mafia howard's
operations were not run as a
militaristic outfit with a rigid
structure codes of honor and
quasi-bureaucratic procedures howard
relied instead on an informal yet
cohesive network of contacts and
friendships which operated smoothly
thanks to a culture of mutual favors and
shared profit such an organization did
not require the use of violence to
operate therefore it didn't attract
excessive scrutiny from police forces
thanks to his network and chameleon-like
skills marx was able to slip in and out
of britain undisturbed shifting tons of
cannabis across continents at a later
stage de agent lovato estimated that
between 1975 and 1978 marx had shipped
to the us 24 loads of marijuana and
hashish for a total of 25 tons of dope
these operations
had involved the mafia the yakuza the
brotherhood of eternal love the thai
army the palestine liberation
organization the pakistani armed forces
nepalese monks and other individuals
from all walks of life the total profit
made by all concerned was 48 million
dollars but clearly this wasn't enough
for mr nice in 1979 marx received 50
tons of cannabis from the trophicantis a
mafia family based in florida he
delivered it to the scottish coast via a
fleet of tugboats yachts and dinghies
unfortunately for him the market was too
well supplied and it took too long to
shift the grass the trafficantes got
restless if barks couldn't sell the dope
fast enough they would take matters into
their own hands a group of them reached
the uk but they weren't very discreet
the customs office put them under
surveillance until they saw them meeting
a tall man who looked a lot like marx
the police launched a series of raids
leading to the arrest of howard and six
associates more importantly they
confiscated the largest consignment of
cannabis ever imported to the uk worth
over 20 million pounds that's 76 million
pounds today or around 103 million
dollars howard couldn't be proud when he
saw the headlines
but he was due for jail as he awaited
trial in 1980 he took the occasion to
marry his latest sweetheart judy lane
their daughter amber age 2 was the
bridesmaid they went on to have two more
children francesca in 1981 and patrick
in 1987. in november 1981 howard went on
trial his defense attorneys performed a
miracle they claimed that at the time of
the tripacante deal marx had an ironclad
alibi he was in mexico your honor an
undercover assignment to combat
terrorism and the trafficking of hard
drugs the defense even produced
passports and hotel bills to
substantiate their claim an unidentified
mexican secret agent showed up to
testify in favor of senior marx all of
this was fabricated of course but it
totally did the trick the trial judge
remarked i hope the jury are following
all of this because i am a little lost
the jury was indeed following many of
its members spellbound by the
charismatic personality of mr knight one
of them was seen doodling a heart
unsurprisingly the jury declared the
defendant not guilty
[Music]
marx was released in 1982 with all
intentions of going straight but in 1983
it was offered the chance to sell 250
kilograms of cannabis he accepted and he
was back in business he established ties
with a provider on the afghani pakistani
border and the two supplied tons of dope
to the u.s entering the market by plane
or boat all the profits were laundered
in travel agencies paper mills or
deposited in safe accounts in hong kong
in that period howard judy and the kids
relocated to palmer de molauka the
balearic islands in spain locals and
other expats howard was a loving father
and husband adored by his children they
could not suspect that mr nice was
running a perfectly oiled drug smuggling
machine spanning five continents but mr
nice did not suspect that a dea agent he
had never met had been shadowing his
every move for years waiting for the
right moment to pounce thanks to british
and dutch investigators craig lovato had
learned that one jim hobbs acted as
marx's phone operator from amsterdam
hobbs picked up phone calls from
associates all over the world and then
connected them to marx's home in palmer
lovato received authority to wiretap the
lines and listen patiently for months
howard and his accomplices were always
careful to speak in code for example
champagne was marijuana or mozambique
stood for mexico and so on these phone
calls could not be used as evidence
nonetheless lovato was able to
reconstruct important nodes in how it
marks his network he learned that his
brothers-in-law george and patrick lane
were essential cogs purchasing drugs
from major suppliers or laundering
profits the big surprise came when
howard connected with an eccentric
british expat in the philippines anthony
patrick andrew carnes berkeley lord
moynihan the aristocrat had made a
fortune managing brothels in the
philippines and was said to travel with
a grenade launcher in the trunk of his
car marx and moynihan hit it off and
sought to make business together mr nice
asked the lord if he could help him buy
land in the philippines to establish his
own marijuana plantation in february of
1986 president of the philippines
ferdinand marcos was deposed after 21
years in office lovato knew that lord
moynihan enjoyed the protection of the
regime with marcos gone he bid his
weakest dea agents flew to manila and
convinced moynihan to cooperate in
exchange for his own immunity his job
would be to wear a hidden microphone to
record incriminating conversations with
marx moynihan delivered and in july 1988
lovato and the spanish police arrested
howard with his wife judy now mrs box
was never part of the organization but
she had picked up some calls on behalf
of howard which was enough for an
indictment as marx was resisting
extradition to the u.s lovato offered a
deal if he accepted to be tried in
america the dea would release judy
howard accepted he went on trial in
florida in 1991. this time he did not
try any creative defense shenanigans
when howard's brother-in-law george
announced he would testify for the
prosecution he agreed to plead guilty mr
nice was sentenced to 25 years to be
served at the terre haute penitentiary
indiana there he acquired a new nickname
narco polo but he also gained a
reputation as a model prisoner popular
with wardens and convicts which he
taught grammar and philosophy eventually
thanks to his good behavior howard marks
was released on parole in 1995
howard emerged from prison a new man
with a new career that of an all-round
entertainer in the span of five years he
appeared on the debut album by the super
furry animals founded record label
bothered worked as a dj and launched a
successful one-man comedy show theaters
were sold out as audiences laughed at
howard's anecdotes of his lawless life
he later collected his stories in the
best-selling autobiography mr nice
adapted into a film starring reese evans
in the lead marx later admitted to a
short relapse into drug dealing in the
mid-1990s he had bought a large quantity
of ecstasy ready to hit the market of
dance clubs but he realized they'd been
sold an adultered batch of pills and
refused to push them the experience
convinced him that synthetic drugs were
too easy to be tampered with they could
not compete with the wholesomeness of
natural drugs that is when he started
campaigning for the legalization of
cannabis even standing for election in
four parliamentary constituencies he did
not win a seat but that did not deter
him from campaigning during the
following decade in the early 2010s marx
was celebrated as a cult figure or folk
hero he continued to publish books even
venturing into crime fiction in the
early 2010s but in january of 2015 he
announced some very sad news to his
admirers he had been diagnosed with
late-stage colorectal cancer in a bbc
interview in october 2015 he revealed he
had tried a variety of treatments with
unintended consequences it took about
eight weeks supply of cannabis oil in
one hit along with everything from
apricot seeds to moths all the crazy
crackpot anti-cancer things that you can
take i just took the lot and got
sectioned and put in the nut house for
two weeks but no treatments neither
experimental nor crackpot could help him
at that stage howard marx died on the
10th of april 2016. our format certainly
could not do justice the myriad of
capers that filled the picturesque life
of today's protagonist that is why i
encourage you to read his autobiography
mr nice i've read it myself it's very
good there's a link in the description
below he left this world leaving a
dilemma behind did he deserve his folk
hero status for issuing violence sale of
hard drugs and efforts to legalize
cannabis or was he just another drug
lord a criminal whose actions should be
condemned i'll leave you with howard's
own reflections from one of his last
interviews pretty much every drug would
be safer to society if legalized and
controlled rather than left up to the
criminal fraternity of course one has to
have the caveat that if a drug is
discovered or synthesized that makes you
want to kill people and rape people then
make it illegal obviously i haven't
taken every drug in the world but i've
taken a lot and i haven't come across
one that makes you like that except
possibly alcohol which is the only one
that's legal so
none of it makes sense to me so i hope
you enjoyed today's video before you
leave let me tell you about a new
channel that i'm doing called into the
shadows so maybe the world isn't dark
enough for you well good news it
absolutely is and if you'd like to know
more about the horrible things that
humans have been doing to each other
since well time immemorial well please
check out that new channel into the
shadows from land mines to penal
colonies to horrific diseases if it's
horrific we cover it check it out
through the link in the description
below again it's called into the shadows
and thank you for watching